you knew it was going to happen here's
the first story we have for you I have
to pull this one up I heard this uh so
it's a tweet from end wokeness Anna
Navarro goes full election denier on CNN
this you have to here to believe but of
course you'll believe it uh here we go
yeah I told you he was going to win
bigly but listen wrong wait I got I'm
sorry she said he's going to win bigly
Trump actually made that word a thing
anyway let's play it again yeah I told
you he was going to win bigly but listen
Ron DeSantis barely won in 2018 by 35
000 votes by the skin of his teeth
against a black Progressive little-known
mayor from Tallahassee Florida it didn't
yesterday he won by 20 percentage points
why because he gained the system because
he turned Florida into an unlevel
playing field they changed election loss
making it harder to vote by mail they
paraded a bunch of people black people
that they arrested for a voting fraud
and paraded them in front of national
media he created an election police he
also yeah I told you he was going to he
created an election police he paraded
people who were arrested for fraud he
made it to heart he made it harder to
vote by mail they call that cheating
it's kind of crazy to me when I first
heard this because she's basically
saying like if you stop people from
committing fraud Republicans will win
I'm like uh
uh is that the message you were going
for because that's what she said that's
crazy essentially I mean after 2000
Florida decided to invest a lot of their
money into voting because there was a
big problem there in 2000 and this year
they banned mail-in ballots they banned
ballot harvesting they they have voter
ID laws and they also created a police
force which I think I think was pretty
interesting but when we look at Florida
they were able to count 99 of their
votes by midnight they were able to do a
quick and effective job at it unlike
Arizona unlike a lot of other states
that that can't even count votes so I I
think it's pretty fair to say that what
they did in Florida was right I think
they they made sure that people were
voting who they were voting for and made
sure that there wasn't any kind of theft
or any kind of shenanigans going on and
I think that's one of the reasons why
DeSantis had such a big victory and
someone needs to tell those ladies
there's a whole bunch of people trying
to escape the blue states that the
policies they vote on made them need to
escape to Florida in this vote for
DeSantis you ever you ever look and see
just how many influencers have now gone
to Florida all of them Dave rubin's in
what Miami now Luke was there but we
snatched him back I'm going to come back
eventually I think but look at all I
mean and you know forget the fact that
you know Anna Paulina Luna she won her
District but you've got so many folks
that are there now uh and again if you
look at the what did he win by against
Gillum like 1.8 percent and now this was
a massive blowout so you see see the
interpretation when I that I take away
from Anna Navarro is this what they're
not looking at is the fact that Rhonda
Santos put in policies that actually
worked made the state free made the
state great people liked it there were a
lot of people who didn't like Ronda
Sanchez to begin with maybe didn't vote
for him four years ago but this time
they said you know what this guy is he's
done it right let's put him back in he
barely won last time he won by what 30
000. it was it was an extremely close
race and now how much did he win by what
what is it one point one point five yeah
1.5 million votes that's that's a lot of
votes Trump didn't like it no obviously
he was angry at that Rhonda said flip
Tampa and Miami
these are I mean it's just it's it's a
it's apocalyptic for for the Democrats
in the state to to turn a city to a
republican majority is just it's just
insane yeah that's amazing no that's
that's the thing you know as Texans we
get frustrated with Greg Abbott because
Greg Abbott often gets lumped in as a
good conservative governor and he's not
uh you know what Rhonda Santos does well
the difference between him and Ron
DeSantis is Ronda Santos does it and
then five days later has a press
conference about it and talks about how
he's already curb stomped everybody down
and done and it's working and then you
got a Greg Abbott who's like you know
putting his finger in the air to see
which way the wind's blowing and putting
a pole out there and he says oh we're
going to do that too aren't we bold and
then he never does it well exactly did
you hear Rhonda Santa's um his speech he
gave that night I swear I was wondering
if that was a swipe at Abbott because he
said he mentioned all the people that
just pull before they make decisions and
he said he makes decisions I said that's
Abbott Greg Abbott spends 25 000 a week
on polls he doesn't make a single
decision without polling wow you can't
trust the politician like that and you
can't try to trust the politician at all
in my opinion and my perspective but we
saw this also during covet specifically
with Ron DeSantis making a lot of the
bigger moves that were criticized by the
corporate media and then only later on
if DeSantis was able to survive the
storm did Texas Implement those same
kind of policies and I think covet is
the biggest thing that a lot of uh
people are paying attention to and
that's what really sets him aside from
Donald Trump that had the opposite
approach of what Ron DeSantis did and
when Donald Trump was criticizing Sweden
because they didn't lock down Florida
was was not locking down as well well
all you got to do is look at this the
bussing the illegals to these cities
okay all you got to look at as a
microcosm of everything else so Greg
Abbott was doing that he was sent him in
Washington D.C sending them to New York
City and and again I I've never approved
of let's take illegals deeper into the
interior of the country that becomes a
problem but he was doing that to try to
make a point he was doing it over and
over again and Ron desantisen's 48
illegals to Martha's Vineyard and over a
course of what 36 hours makes all the
headlines all the news because he sent
them strategically to the right place it
wasn't New York it wasn't Washington DC
where they could just blend in and quote
assimilate now Martha's Vineyard where
he knew they were going to stand out
more than anybody else and it was
effective it was effective we got more
people talking about it was the ultimate
troll uh using human beings which it's
unfortunate situation but but look at
the attention it garnered yeah it was
unfortunate because Martha's Vineyard
was bigoted and kicked them out
there and then they still patted
themselves on the back for like hand and
not blankets or something gave him a
Pop-Tart and said you know
Amigos bye-bye they gave him a 50 gift
card
Joe Biden was trafficking uh was was
flying around these these kids and he
probably still is they they kept lying
and saying it wasn't happening then
video comes out out of Westchester New
York where the skies like if the
American people found out what we were
doing then you get video coming out of I
think it was Tennessee where they're
like yep the bite Administration is
flying these these illegal immigrant
children into various parts of this
country then you had that statement from
that sheriff in Ohio where he said ice
would be like hey can you hold these
guys temporarily for us while we're
processing they go yeah for sure and
then they ghost them just leaving them
there in Ohio all of that was okay
Rhonda Santa sends one time 48 people
and it was the apocalypse it was it and
listen if you go down anybody that's a
denier of that and again for those who
don't know I I ran in the primary
against Greg Abbott I ran in the
Republican primary against Greg Abbott
for governor of Texas all right it was a
I have no political clout no desire to
be a politician but if everybody thought
it was a joke if there was a publicity
stunt 19 months later they knew I was
serious we did what we did and it was an
education thing we got people involved
in the primary that had never been
involved before you go down to McAllen
Texas you go down you stand in the
airport and you look around you will
literally see hundreds of illegals
walking around with the manila envelope
on the outside of it printed in English
says I do not speak English I need you
to help me get to my gate you don't know
what's inside of the papers or the
envelope other than papers that say we
have a ticket to go wherever we want to
go in the country it's happening they're
moving them all over look at that right
there I mean and if you listen my friend
my friend Weston Martinez that ran for a
land commissioner he carries in his
pocket a a
piles one of these cards right here he
carries a pile of them in his pocket at
any given time and they're all Haitians
that are coming through the southern
border they were displaced after the the
hurricane or the Earth that's a fake ID
that was left here by Lord miles
Rutledge on his travels he was on the
board he said there's tons of him he had
a stack of them he was like here I'll
leave this one yeah you can go down to
the you can go down the Rio Grande River
I mean you will find there's stacks of
those that's what I said yeah well and
the funny thing is is like you know
they're going to try to they well like I
said they pat themselves on the back for
welcoming welcoming them but they don't
even understand the bigger reason why
you want the Border closed is not only
for us because we can't house them just
like you couldn't in Martha's Vineyard
but it's also completely dangerous like
there's been record numbers of illegal
aliens died this year under the Biden
Administration it's unsafe for them too
it cranberry it's crime here but if you
have a heart for illegals which I always
have been trying to appeal for the
people and telling them why we want the
Border clothes but I I want to point
this out too
um I just went and saw wakanda forever
black black panther too I told you guys
about it I don't I'm not going to spoil
it because I know a lot of people may
want to go see it I thought the movie
was enjoyable and it was also one of the
most extremely racist films I mean it's
crazy the first black panther was a an
ethno nationalist versus like an ethno
supremacist that was the first black
panther the reason I bring this up in
this context because I will give you
guys a little bit of a spoiler the movie
was basically like I I don't want to
spoil too much but it was an extreme
racist stereotype about
um Mexican illegal immigrants and that's
the that's the funny thing when you were
telling me I thought it was going to be
like blacks against white or or dominant
Paradigm kind of thing but it totally
that's a turn I didn't expect yeah if
you watch the trailer you will see that
there's two characters there's uh you
know t'challa has passed away that's
that's in the trailer everyone knows
that because Chadwick Boseman passed a
rest in peace and uh in the movie you
have wakanda this African nation and
then Neymar who is another Marvel
character is basically a Mexican guy he
is Yucatan Mayan so they have a lot of
Mexican you know Heritage and symbols
and stuff and this is what the movie's
about if you watch the trailer you can
basically understand without me spoiling
anything that um I I can't get into it
without spoiling a key component of the
film but
holy was it like
an overt message about
Mexicans and South American illegal
immigrants and I was just like yikes man
like that wow and I'm sure a bunch of
woke people are gonna are gonna
celebrate it oh for sure but I just had
to bring it up because I just saw it and
it's like on my mind I wish I could
spoil it it'd be so good but I can't I
was like shocked when you told me yeah
did you see it no I didn't see it I came
in like we were in the car coming back
from it and just like that whole movie
oh man I can't I can't spoil it I just
wish I could but wild it's wild it's
like Donald Trump is probably sitting
there pointing his finger like that
Leonardo DiCaprio like that that you all
ever follow it there's a guy on
Instagram and followers he he takes the
old like uh Justice League Comics his
name is Ace vain he takes the old
Justice League comics and he does the
voiceovers but but it's like he's black
right he's it's very much you know so so
they capture Aquaman and I'm not gonna
give this away I'm gonna do this
creatively they capture Aquaman they got
him in like a cage and he's like I'm
gonna do some medieval [ __ ] on this dude
and he's like what are you gonna do to
him man he goes I'm gonna drown him
what so
you telling me that story reminded me a
little bit of that and of course yeah I
just when you when folks see the movie
they'll do it they'll know exactly six
months you can reveal it we it's just
it's crazy that we've got uh in politics
the board are such a big issue and then
you literally have this move this movie
I'll I'll say this thing I'll say one
thing
it's not a spoiler it's in the trailer
in the trailer there is a scene showing
the the Mexican water people
entering wakanda
and so you get the point I'm gonna
explain that's in the trailer but like
the ending was just like they may as
well have come out and just started
spitting racial slurs I was just like
it's funny though I bring it up just
because it's a such a big political
issue and like woke people have been
celebrating black panther like the first
movie as this like great Triumph of
diversity or whatever and I'm like it's
just one of like the whole thing is
racial racial stereotypes this is not a
spoiler it's just a scene in the movie
the the the wakandans are are control
are using computer controls by by
banging on drums and I was just I'm like
it was just way over the top way over
the top no condom forever thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time